so juggling is pretty hard at least for
me it is I want to get to three balls
there's just natural question right it's
like before five what's the limit this
guy definitely knows hi I'm Alex Barron
and I hold the world record for most
balls juggle that's 11 and I also hold
the world record for something called
most balls flashed and that's 14 that's
right
alex has flashed 14 balls flash just
means throwing a certain number of balls
in the air and catching that many balls
in sequence one time here he is laughing
13 but is 14 balls the limit today we're
gonna look at white juggling 15 balls
might be almost impossible to learn what
it takes I got a lesson from Barren it's
close talk with a juggling pro about the
patterns and science that make it
possible to keep so many balls up in the
air and with someone who doesn't even
have to see the balls to juggle people
have been juggling for millennia this
Egyptian painting of women juggling is
nearly 4,000 years old and it's always
seemed like a bit of magic even three
ball juggling is mesmerizing to watch
but performers have always been pushing
the limit for higher numbers back in the
1920s famed juggler Enrico rastelli was
said to have juggled ten balls in for a
while that seemed like the upper limit
for continuous juggling people could
match it but nobody can really exceed it
that was until 2012 when Baron managed
this astounding feat 11 balls for 23
catches I think it feels good yeah like
I was very happy when I go the world
records I mean I wouldn't have spent so
many hours doing it if I didn't care
about it Baron started juggling as a kid
you know determined to be like one of
the youngest people to do 11 like for a
flash you know first you're like oh yeah
like I learned five and like you hear
people talking on the internet about how
how hard five is you know my car I'm
gonna like I'm gonna be able to do five
and then it just kind of keeps going
man so I don't think I'll ever have the
time or maybe more likely the patients
never become the serious numbers and
juggler but I can already do three so
Baron gave me some lessons on how I
could do so if I want to graduate from
three balls to five balls you're talking
about some of the things I need to work
on are my actual hand speed yeah and how
high I'm throwing the ball because it's
the time in between the throws right
exactly yeah you'll have to go higher
and faster okay so show me how they yeah
that works yeah so if five I'm gonna end
up throwing them about eye level or a
little bit higher as it hosts a lower
with three but otherwise it's the same
really the motion is very similar you
just have to be a little bit more fluid
and you know move your hands have been
faster the hardest bit is to start
because that's when you go all the
weight in your hands right so to begin
with yeah I just try don't even worry
about catching them just go one two
three four five here we go I'm just
gonna do one two three four five see if
I can just get them all up in the air or
if I can throw the last ball before the
first one comes down right even faster
with looks pretty good yeah and if it
goes really well what you want to see is
two little piles one for each am pretty
good I managed to pull off a lucky flash
when the cameras weren't rolling and I'm
still working on doing it continuously
like really working on it these days
five is just a warm-up for Baron he can
do seven without much trouble and makes
it look effortless but when he starts
going for big numbers like nine ten
eleven all the way up to fourteen he
usually heads indoors to a squash court
we're outside right now yes it's a
little windy that has something to do
with why you practice in squash courts
yes
well wind obviously is gonna mess up
your pattern a little bit you want the
balls to have a very consistent
trajectory every single time you try and
the squash courts have really good
contrast too because it's basically a
white background so typically it's much
easier to see and even though you're not
looking at one ball in particular your
subconscious is still taking in where
they all are
in the sky and where they're coming down
so keeping an eye on the balls at the
top of their arc or apex is critical for
Berens big numbers you look vaguely at
the apex of the pattern and then from
that you have some sense of what the
pattern looks like whether it's slanted
off-kilter there's not like me
registering each throw and going on that
was a good one that was a bad one
I guess I do think that was a bad one if
I do a bad throw I typically notice that
ball in particular but that's not the
only way to juggle a lot of balls my
name is Zach McAllister I hold three
different records for BBB which stands
for blind behind the back juggling I
hold the record for doing it five six
and seven McCallister doesn't have to
look at the balls at all he feels for
their apex I'll start with them behind
the back and I'll make my first throw
and once the throw is made then I wait
to feel it hit my elbow and once I feel
that then I know it's ready for the next
ball usually in my head I will feel out
be like okay at this point when I feel
this I need to make this next throw once
I feel it coming down to my wrists then
I know that I need to open up my hand
and have it ready so that way it can
make the catch it is crazy
impressive but McAllister thinks he's at
the numbers limit for blind behind the
back as you increase each ball you start
to realize I'm running out of space on
my back and four balls isn't too bad but
once you hit five balls then you're
starting to realize like I need to
either like start making my throws a
little higher than my elbow which is not
ideal because then it's even more blind
and I have to think about it even more
which takes up to like seven so you just
have to hope that they all work out
traditional numbers jugglers don't have
that kind of limit in fact the sky is
literally their limit but it seems like
there are physical barriers to getting
more balls in the air let's talk about
15 for a second for example just four
there for the flash I do think there's a
physiological barrier there where
someone will have to train very very
specifically for flashing that number
doing 15
is gonna require a level of strength
which is considerably beyond what I have
in the moment to learn more I talked
with Jack Calvin he's a professional
juggler and former engineer and he's
writing a book on human performance and
juggling Calvin has been measuring
juggling hand speed with an
accelerometer in a smartphone app so
naturally we asked Alex Barron to try it
out first Calvin had him juggle
progressively higher numbers of balls do
you want to try it a run of nine and
then he had him try an absurdly fast
perhaps not surprisingly Baron topped
Calvin's charts balls according to his
maximum hand speed when he shook his
hand as fast as he could it was
equivalent to juggling 23 to 25 balls so
he's actually nowhere near his limit
according to his hand speed that's crazy
but according to Calvin speed is not the
only limit when it comes to numbers
juggling basically what it found is that
hand speed is not the main limiting
factor of of juggling it's actually the
accuracy there's a few different degrees
of accuracy but the first degree would
be able to throw something up so that it
lands within reach the other is is the
space that you have in the air and
having to avoid collisions between
objects of course I wanted to find out
how I stack up so I strapped on the
accelerometer go have three ball data
here okay one do two in one hand yeah
[Music]
put the balls down and shake your hand
as fast as you can come on faster you
can go faster than that the hell you got
come on and according to Calvin's
calculations your maximum amount was
fourteen point one balls sweet so so if
I practice really diligently I could
maybe flash the 14 you could you I have
the hand speed to flash 14 balls just
like Alex okay but you
probably accuracy so I'm still working
on five but it's nice to know that I
have the hand speed to do more than that
if I keep practicing in fact according
to Jack's research most people probably
have the hand speed to do as many as not
know so hand speed is definitely a
factor to consider here but here's
another big one how do you even hold
this many balls jugglers call it the
grip so yeah in terms of the grip we
start off just a very simple one in each
hand we move to two you end up with a
little line this one further out goes
first three is a little triangle I like
to release this one first four so some
people stack it on top which maybe you
do for lower numbers but we're gonna go
high so we can't do that quite yet
you're not this little diamond five I
like this kind of trapezium shape six in
one hand suddenly you get this pretty
ugly two lines of three deal this one as
you can see is pretty compressed there's
probably the worst one to release if you
get up to 14 then you just shove the
last two on top three anytime you can
shove the last two on top but with 14
we're forced to go like this I do these
little setup throws to try and get them
in the right position Baron is a pretty
tall guy he's over six feet tall and
he's got big hands but what about the
rest of us
[Music]
okay so not all of us are up for massive
numbers juggling 14 but there are other
ways to impress mathematically of course
there's the beauty of something called
siteswap so side swap is a way of
notating juggling patterns so you can
throw balls at different heights when
you juggle and the way jugglers
typically denote those different heights
is they do it based on how high you'd
have to throw to juggle a certain number
of balls so for three balls I can do it
like really low like this right if I
pick up five balls just because there
are more balls I've got to throw it
higher to do the same thing so what
siteswaps lets you do is combine throws
from different numbers of balls and you
just call those throw who's the number
of balls so a simple one for example
with four balls would be something
called five three four and so if I was
just doing four right they all go the
same height so this is lots of fours
over and over again what I can do is I
can throw one ball higher to be a five
and then one below to be a three and
then go back to four so that's like five
three four you can see there's a five
ball throw a three ball throw and then
you can either do five three
continuously or you can mix it up and
yeah what's fun about that is now if you
want to tell your friend hey I found
this great in your juggling pattern you
just give them a list of numbers and
then they can do it right they can try
and learn at least sites warred can even
be a way to practice juggling greater
numbers according to Kelvin siteswap is
a way that you can that some people
practice higher numbers using a lower
number of balls in this pattern you're
actually throw one hand is doing the
work of five balls one hand is is is
doing exactly is doing half of a five
ball of pattern and the other hand is
doing a one ball pattern
that's useful because practicing big
numbers can be a serious workout the raw
physical act of it like the speed at
which you have to move your hands the
amount of weight that you have in your
hands at the beginning is on a different
level people tend to see in the juggling
world going from an even number to an
odd number as being substantially harder
than going from an odd number to an even
number with even numbers you can throw
them in pairs which means you can get
your whole body involved with fifteen
you'd have to do it asynchronously the
biggest question mark for me is probably
whether someone has the physical ability
to practice 15 enough to be able to do
it or have enough attempts to be lucky
enough to catch 15 balls because of
course there's like luck involved
between the practice needed to perfect
technique and the strength and speed
required to keep the balls in the air
Baron thinks his record will stand but
he's eager to see it challenged yeah
like do I think someone will ever do 15
for a flash I like to think someone will
do 15 I mean I you know you compare this
to like 100-meter sprint or marathon or
something where countless people have
optimized themselves as hard as they can
and trained for it I think there's
there's more to go in juggling for sure
I don't know what if that's within my
personal limits that tend to find out
over the next ten years or so beyond
that I mean yes I think there is a
physical limit at some point right and
for me it's hard to conceive of juggling
16 or 17 or flashing 16 or 17 balls
maybe I should say that 15 is impossible
and then some guy will come up on the be
like or some girl and be like no like
through you like I'm gonna do it
so I've been practicing a few minutes
every day and every once in a while I
will get lucky and flash five and I
finally managed to do it on camera
yeah oh sure there's hope but it's not
like I'm ever gonna challenge somebody
like bear and that's totally fine
because what he's doing is already
almost impossible
you